I jokingly told you that in the era of
Trump suddenly everybody's an expert on
trade deals and globalization and
geopolitics and manufacturing and
importing and exporting whatever and if
that's true that now everybody knows
about trade and all of this stuff then
we should be hearing the complaints very
soon about Donald Trump's newly proposed
renegotiation of NAFTA the North
American Free Trade Agreement Trump
campaigned on this right Trump has been
talking for a long time about how NAFTA
is bad and he's going to renegotiate it
and TPP the trans-pacific partnership is
bad and Trump is going to get rid of it
now it just so happened that by the time
Donald Trump was inaugurated in January
of 2017 TPP was already dead it had been
dead for months back in October of 2016
you had Republicans and Democrats saying
yeah it's just not going to happen the
u.s. is not going to sign on to TPP but
in any case Donald Trump still took
credit for it when he was inaugurated in
January of 2017 the latest is that the
White House has now released Trump's
proposal for renegotiating NAFTA
and it looks a lot like TPP it looks a
lot like the trans-pacific partnership
deal which Donald Trump said was
terrible it has a ton of provisions that
are like the supposedly bad
trans-pacific partnership if you look at
the provisions about the regulation of
the treatment of workers it's almost
identical to trans-pacific partnership
if you look at the provisions in Trump's
new version of NAFTA about the
environment and state-owned businesses
it looks just like they ripped a page
out of TPP Trump was against TPP and now
he's proposing something that looks like
it has numerous elements that came
straight out of TPP and investors would
also have the ability under this
investor-state dispute settlement system
to go to an extrajudicial court for a
sort of inter-country disputes which was
one of the main areas of TPP that so
many of us and Trump were critical of
and like most Trump proposals it's so
vague that it's almost useless
Democratic Senator Ron Wyden put out a
statement about Trump's new renegotiated
NAFTA proposal saying it's quote
hopelessly vague and that many of the
areas of it look like watered down
versions of TPP Trump claimed that
renegotiating NAFTA would be this huge
win for the American people this
proposal doesn't achieve that it has a
lot of the same Pro corporate and anti
little guy in the United States
provisions that the trans-pacific
partnership have and trumpets are never
going to get how much of a scam this is
and think about the evil genius here
Trump opposed TPP claimed to get us out
of it even though it was already dead by
the time he was inaugurated and then he
delivers a NAFTA renegotiation that
includes a ton of the pieces of TPP and
his supporters might actually give him
credit for two achievements from his
campaign promises ending TPP which he
didn't and renegotiating NAFTA for them
even though it's basically a watered
down version of TPP and the trumpets
will never know and they will say look
at how much he's getting done it's
amazing there are some viewers of ours
and listeners who get exactly what's
going on and they've started a
discussion about it over on our reddit
discussion forum and you can check that
out at david pakman.com slash read it
but you know what if you're
participating in a discussion about this
on our reddit discussion forum you're
probably not one of these uninformed
Trumpets who believe that this is yet
another one of donald trump's great
victories it is sad but this is the type
of thing that could bring Trump to
re-election in 2020 today's program is
made possible in part by Gamefly which
is sort of like netflix for video games
they've got over 8,000 new and classic
games for xbox one Xbox 360 ps4 ps3 Wii
and a bunch of other platforms and you
can also stream games you don't even
need a gaming console or a computer
because you can stream games through
your Amazon fire stick or Roku box and
then use your mobile phone as the
controller you can play as many games as
you want for one monthly fee and if you
find some games you want to keep you can
buy them for a low used price never with
due dates or late fees and our audience
can get a 30-day free trial at Gamefly
offered.com slash TDP s the games are
shipped directly to you with return
envelopes included no contracts and you
can also stream the games I think I
mentioned that you can also rent games
through the mobile app get a free 30 day
trial for David Pakman show viewers and
listeners and support our show at
Gamefly offer.com forward slash TDP s